why is everything so hard
this is a wonderful comedy and it's
about more than just trying for a family
that it's hard it's about people and
life
show me your best manager point
wow you're ready i love that nikki is
banging her own drum but i feel like
she's found with jason that he just
allows her to be herself
it's a real matter of fact until you
make it in my personal life
and also for jason he's just trying to
be a grown-up because apparently he got
a big round out to have kids
how'd it go really well i managed to
convince them
to give you the job no to keep my
current one so everyone in series two is
kind of having their own
malfunctions of life every character has
flaws but they're so
lovable at the same time i need a bit of
relationship advice i'm single and i'm
at a wedding with my wife and her
boyfriend so yeah i'm definitely your
guy
freddie is lost in a world where he
doesn't have the anchor of his wife and
his kids
yeah i think he's learning hard lessons
i was never here this is an illusion
okay okay
there is a boy you'd think the social
worker is terribly organized
terribly calm because penny is chaotic
and crazy and mad and that's just
was wonderful to play amen
namaste the doubts that karen has about
her relationship with scott
sort of bubbled to the surface in season
two
you've got to take more responsibility
i've been babysitting it's not even
called that when they're yours
it's really comforting to watch other
people making mistakes and you kind of
feel reassured that everyone makes
mistakes i think everyone
is trying to slowly figure it all out
i'm not sure we
ever do really properly figure it all
out though i've figured it out
no you haven't
[Music]
you